now we've created a new caste system a
new aristocracy so a victim often
self-proclaimed well say I've got all
these grievances and I'm owed and I need
those addressed and society's left
saying well if we say sorry and try and
make them hope you'll appreciate it but
no they'll say we were owed hmm if you
don't then you confirm that victimhood
and you're a hater or a racist or or
whatever but here's the rub if your
power comes from being a victim you have
every interest in ensuring that your
victim what is never address that you
remain a victim
I think Douglas Murray species is right
you've had a whole series of movements
to correct things that have needed
correcting in the West and by the way
what system delivers the ability to
peacefully correct things that are wrong
better than liberal participate or
democracy and you think of the civil
rights movement and that incredible
speech I look forward to the day when my
children are judged by the content of
their character not the color of their
skin so all of these movements you know
I mean I have three daughters it's
incredibly important to me that they're
paid properly for their work or whatever
it happens to me as Douglas Murray says
you know that train has moved with a lot
of cabooses in its carriage under the
platform it's starting to slow down with
my tremendous progress if you like in
Martin Luther's language those who have
been marginalized and sidelined have
been allowed to join the citizenry
mm-hmm and all of a sudden the Train the
governor's let go and just when you're
getting close to the station it's taken
off so how do you untether people from
that then right so so I've heard
Douglass talk about this I've discussed
it with him but how do you then untether
people from the idea that they're still
oppressed when they're no longer
oppressed
if oppression can be used to control
people that's a pretty addicting feeling
right there well this is the great
problem I think of victimhood politics
now why a good friend of mine from the
left in Australia a very noble old
classic sort of Australian socialist
and I've always regarded him as a man of
noble intent and he says you know look
we were about in the labor movement
universalism so if someone was oppressed
or sidelined or not being looked after
properly the idea was to elevate their
status so that they were part of the
citizenry that's what Martin Luther King
was trying to do in this country but now
we've created a new caste system a new
aristocracy so a victim often self
proclaimed well so I've got all these
grievances and I'm owed and I need those
addressed and societies that saying well
if we say sorry and try and make them I
hope you'll appreciate it but no they'll
say we were owed hmm if you don't then
you confirm that victimhood and you're a
hater or a racist or or whatever but
here's the rub if your power comes from
being a victim you have every interest
in ensuring that your victim who does
never address that you remain a victim
and that's why you can't untether it
from that train well I actually cannot
say to you I think this is proving to be
such an unsatisfactory philosophy for
people who find themselves you know the
rush for a university student oh I'm a
victim I moan but as I think it through
I think and you and I've seen this I
think there's a lot of people realizing
that's not very sustaining and in the
end I don't want to be a victim I want
to be a full member of a community and I
want to pull my weight and we've got a
plight of the better angels isn't it
funny that we know in in real life when
you're around friends or family people
that you socialize with nobody wants to
be around a victim nobody wants to be
around someone endlessly complaining of
them you want to be around people that
that impress you that inspire you that
make you laugh that have joy in the
world that can share something good with
you and yet somehow a movement has been
created that somehow seems sexy based on
something that is so anti how any of us
if we really thought about our lives
would ever really want to be hey let's
let's be clear I think you and I would
agree on this there are people that very
legitimate absolutely the paper novel is
a king was talking about if I can say
this in your country somebody who's not
American I mean those grievances were
deep and real and roar and horrible for
anybody has studied Jimmy Crow and what
happened
and then it's extraordinary yeah I hope
you don't mind me saying that no no of
course is it you're saying you're saying
you just I did I mean the whole point is
to lift yourself out of it and join the
rest of the community I mean the great
again their hackneyed to death I know
everybody talks about it but Kennedy ask
not what your country can do for you but
what you can do for your country we've
reversed it if we reverse the idea of
citizenship so now we say I demand my
country meet my needs but as you say you
don't want to stay there one of the most
remarkable men in Australia is just
retired he's a very old man now that was
the man Frank Lowy behind the
Westfield's I sue them even here in
America shopping centers oh yeah we've
got one right here now his whole family
he escaped the Holocaust but his family
was wiped out he was a little boy one
day watched his father go off for work
and he never came back
and he talks about how he sat in the
window day after day after day set by
the window where he for dad to come home
dad never did geez
and the whole Holocaust thing oh that
was appalling I mean how any human being
could do what the Nazis did to other
human beings is beyond my comprehension
but if a man like that had spent the
rest of his life saying I am a victim
I'm out fix up my victimhood now I feel
deeply for what he went through but I
respect him hugely for saying I'm not
going to play the victim card and he's
gone out and created jobs for goodness
only knows how many Australians I see
shopping centers here in America and say
oh it's been a success story and we can
sympathize with what he went through but
we can delight in the fact that he has
chosen to be a positive forward-looking
person and if you like has confronted
those demons by rising above them and
denying them oxygen if I can put it that
way yeah so that's before we go too far
down the political rabbit hole because I
can sense where the richness of this
conversation is I just want to talk
about your story a little bit you you
come from a sixth generation farming
family and somehow went into politics
can you explain a little bit of that
yeah Scottish ancestry which is very
common in rural Australia and in rural
Australia farming and grazing was the
way to go
it's a rough
we do farming because of the unreliable
climate Scots were very good at it
because they it's cotton this poor my
end and a rough line and so you know my
family's home I regard if I've done one
brilliant thing I chose my parents world
good move good move and you know the
thing is that so I've been very
fortunate I've seen them go through a
terrible ups and downs my family was
decimated by both the first and second
world war because Australia was deeply
integrated in both double the number of
Australians died in the first world wars
did Americans it was extraordinary the
level of engagement it international
fairs at Australia's taken up even when
it was very young but yeah I am now I
went to school and university in Sydney
and I had never contemplated a political
career I was always fascinated by the
great debates and a voice in our society
as a result of fierce debates that are
not personalised at the best you know
we're the result of the clash of great
ideas look at the debates that went into
the independence of America the thinking
the depth of understanding the belief in
the Worth and dignity of all which is
where your freedom motive my belief
comes from in this country but I was
literally headhunted by retiring federal
member at the precocious age of 27 he
said I'm going to retire I think you
should have a go in my place and I said
well that's sir and what did he see in
you if you were coming from a farming
family what did he know about you that
he thought this guy could do it well
it's an interesting question in a way
that I can answer it honestly I'd been
at a public meeting where he'd said
something about he was from you know the
conservative side of politics he said
something about the left side of
politics and I thought he'd completely
missed the point so I stood up and
remonstrate it firmly but not personally
and he actually said to me I think you
should have a go because you said
something I said something that you
disagreed with and you took it up in a
good humor but a filthy way without
attacking me that's what he actually
said to me so and that's basically what
your guiding principle has been
throughout politics and now even out of
politics I mean you're having
conversations Jordan I sat down with you
for your show which was in front of a
live group of people and it was exactly
this it was exactly let's let's work
through the
stuff instead of you know breaking each
other's backs well I just saw it's
deeply deeply believed and it stems from
my Christian belief that I'm not it's
not for me to judge others is for me to
engage in the contest of ideas and I
oughta balloon passionately in you know
in a vigorous debate you know our
Parliament in Australia is very
adversarial mm-hmm and people often
complain about it and I say look let's
split this into its two components you
actually want your parliamentarians to
believe in things deeply and there ought
to be a great clash over people's
versions of how best to take the place
forward what you're really objecting to
I hope it's not that class of ideas but
when it's personal hmm when people give
or take offence I've just never seen the
point of it I've never seen that it's
taken anybody anywhere if you're looking
for more honest and thoughtful
conversations about politics instead of
non-stop yelling check out our politics
playlist and if you want to watch full
interviews on a variety of topics watch
our full episode playlists all right
over here and to get notified of all
future videos be sure to subscribe and
click the notification bell